foreign
we've renovated 125 year old church that
was an eyesore and made it gorgeous and
a number one attraction as a tourist
attraction in Denver thousands of
tourists come visit our church every
week and spend their money in our
neighborhood at our local shops at our
coffee shops at our bars at our
restaurants so we've stimulated the
economy we've done something that is
totally inclusive and yet the city of
Denver is really encapsulating the
perfect example of big government
passing unnecessary laws that don't
protect anyone and infringing on our
first amendment rights so you'd think
liberal City you know liberal government
they'd welcome this cool new religion
that is welcoming and bringing local
people to the neighborhood and
stimulating the economy you'd think
they'd love us
but they don't and you know we're
showing people that you know if you
fight for your first amendment rights
you are
Defending Your American Liberty and
that's a really important thing even in
left-leaning cities and states
my name is Steve Burke I am the
co-founder of the International Church
of cannabis we are a 501c3 religious
organization based in Denver Colorado
with over 18 000 members the sculpture
was a gift from the artist because he
wanted us to have something that
defended our right to religious liberty
which we thought was amazing because
we've been under attack for pretty much
most of the time we've existed
we installed the sculpture in late
September of 2022 a city inspector was
there the very next day because we can
only assume that one or two of the
neighbors thought it was ugly and
complaint that's fine not everyone's
gonna like art
but
we received no violation we received no
notice from the city they have my phone
number they have my email address
fast forward to February 7th of 2023 we
receive a notice from the city that says
it's a violation and if we don't have a
permit by February 17th we must remove
this sacred sculpture
10 days is not enough time to receive a
land use survey and Engineers study all
the things that we need to apply for a
permit it's impossible so the city
basically gave us a deadline that was
impossible to meet but because it's a
sculpture representing our religious
freedom and the city doesn't quite
understand our religion they don't like
it and they gave us an ultimatum to take
it down and we told them no it's our
First Amendment right to have this
sculpture here it is not dangerous to
anyone it doesn't impede traffic it
doesn't impede traffic sight lines so no
we're not going to take it down I think
the city of Denver thought we created
this church as an excuse to smoke weed
and we didn't need to do that you can
smoke weed anywhere in Denver we created
this church to give a safe place for
adults who use cannabis on their
spiritual journey our religion is
welcoming to everyone it's welcoming to
Christians it's welcoming to Buddhists
it's welcoming to Jewish people we
welcome atheists as long as you believe
that you want to elevate yourself to a
better version of self you are an
elevationist and you don't even
necessarily need to use cannabis to be
an elevationist you can be an
elevationist and not smoke weed so the
city of Denver just doesn't really
understand that we can create a religion
which is our First Amendment right in
this country that we can create a
religion that welcomes people of all
different faiths and backgrounds to come
and have a place where they feel safe
and consume cannabis on their spiritual
journey I don't know how this is going
to play out I hope the city of Denver
recognizes our right to exist and our
right to have this
religious Effigy this this
representation of the freedom of
religion that all Americans should have
the right to to practice and we hope
they just let bygones be bygones and and
let the forces of bureaucracy just rest
and just let this beautiful sculpture
exist